This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast was one of the episodes that we
made while we were filming the Scifi show.
Joe Rogan questions everything.
So what we did when we did that show,
if you've never seen or heard of it,
we had a podcast on the show and a lot of people thought it was a fake podcast,
but it was actually a real podcast and thanks to the generosity of the Scifi
channel,
we are now able to release it as a podcast.
So a thank you to Tim and Wayne,
uh,
from Psi Phi and a to a Michael and frank from uh,
Arthur Smith that produced the show.
Thanks also to Todd who was the director of the show.
We had a great time doing it and uh,
appreciate it very much and appreciate you guys letting me do this like that.
Like the way we did it.
I think it was a,
it was really fun to do it this way.
We did it exactly like a regular podcast,
just me and Duncan.
And in this episode we went over what's called a biohacking or um,
what,
what I call dorks with knives sticking things under their skin.
Fascinating subject and uh,
I think you'll enjoy the shit out of it.
This episode is brought to you by legal zoom.
Legal Zoom is a one of the sponsors that we have where we have actually many
people that are connected to the show have used it on,
it was formulated through legal zoom.
Brian,
um,
made his company in LLC through legal zoom.
It's a way you can do things online where you can get legal papers filed and do
things without actually having to go to an attorney and sit down and,
you know,
pay for an office visit and pay exorbitant amounts of money to an attorney.
And also you have to have a schedule shit and drive and all that jazz.
You can use legal zoom naked.
You could be naked.
Nobody,
nobody can stop you.
You know,
you could make it a point to only use legal zoom when you're naked and won't
have any benefit or any detriment to the actual legal legality of the papers
that you,
that you make.
Like what kind of stuff can you do?
Well,
here's one you can incorporate or form an llc@legalzoom.com starting at just 99
bucks.
That's really easy.
They can help out with trademarks,
copyrights,
patents.
If you've got a great idea and you want to protect it,
if you have a family,
you can make a will.
You can make a legal will for just 69 bucks.
You can also get living trust,
power of attorney and more.
In the past 12 years,
over 2 million Americans have used legal zoom and they've saved a shitload of
money.
Now you get a special discount from listening to this podcast.
Make sure you enter Rogan in the referral box at checkout for more savings.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm.
They provide self help services at your specific direction.
And if everything's spirals out of control and you're in a panic,
they actually can connect you with an independent attorney if you need
additional guidance.
So checkout legal,
zoom.com and see how they can help you today.
Use the code Rogan in the referral box in now without
any further ado,
um,
the podcasts that we did on bio hacking with Duncan Trussell and me.
All right.
The Joe Rogan experience Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
No,
it's really crazy.
Your mom,
after that,
one of your Stepdad's,
isn't that like an interesting sort of a,
of a snap back from that,
you know,
like she's probably around this crazy guy with guns.
Oh fucker.
Give me a gay guy.
He has a kid.
My mom did.
My Dad was like really violent cop and she married a hippie.
Like when she broke up with him,
my stepfather had long hair until I was like 15 years old here.
Like a ponytail.
Who's a total complete hippie,
crazy stoner architect,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
Well he went back.
You don't want to date hunter s Thompson,
you don't want to be around.
Was that your dad hunter s Thompson Shooting Shit?
Yeah,
still is.
He is.
He's,
he's,
he's still traveled around in a a car RV.
Just seeing the world.
Yeah,
he will now he's just,
no,
now he's like local and the Alabama,
but he like goes hunting deer still.
And He,
like I told you the fist fight thing,
right?
No,
this is the weirdest thing.
My,
I was getting a ride.
This is a quick story.
I was getting a ride back from college with my friend Sean.
He recording all this.
Yeah.
My friend Shawn is driving back to,
uh,
was,
was driving to,
I'm immobile where his dad lived and on the way back I'm riding with,
with this guy and he's like,
oh dude,
I forgot to ask.
I want to ask you,
this is your dad's name,
Julian.
And I'm like,
yeah,
Joey.
And Trust me,
he's like,
your dad assaulted my dad and a bar.
My Dad,
my dad beat up my friend's dad from in college.
But when did this happen?
This was w w the the assault happened.
Yeah,
I think before me and this guy were in college together.
But if you look at the probability of getting a ride back from college with a
guy who was immobile,
the probability of your dad having beaten his dad up,
it's so slim.
It's so slim that like my,
what are the odds that my,
that we both go to this liberal arts college of 500 students and the one other
guy from mobile,
Alabama,
his father had been assaulted by my father and a bar.
Those are pretty small and minuscule odds.
It's pretty funny too that it would be your dad too because you're like the
opposite.
Like I could never imagine you just assaulting someone.
Even if somebody got really mad at you,
you'd be like,
all right,
well fuck you man.
And you just like get out of there.
The idea of you assaulting someone is beyond comprehension.
So the idea of your dad being this fucking tooth bullet
and savage beating the fuck out of your friend's dad getting arrested.
Jesus Christ got arrested in the parking lot.
Two cops took him down and he kind of,
my dad
came home from high school once with a black eye,
him and his,
uh,
his,
coworker,
they were doing a business together and the business started going bad.
They got the fucking fist fight and he came home and I remember looking at him,
I was like 16 or 17 or something like that in a blackout.
I was like,
what the fuck man,
are you done with this?
You're still duking it out,
you know,
40,
whatever the hell will heal old.
He was back then.
Well it's a classic.
It's a classic.
It's a classic man.
It's weird.
A classic man.
Fuck.
Like it was like,
like thinking a Hemingway.
That's what's just part of being a man.
It's like you would get in it some inevitable fistfight and in those days it
seems like you don't get in a fist fight and there's lawsuits and legal staff.
It's just like the other guy excepts getting his ass kicked.
You're the victor and that's it.
Or you get your ass kicked and you forget about it.
That seems like the old way.
It is now.
If you get in a fist fight,
you end up in,
you know,
a serious legal trouble,
you get all the instant lawsuit.
But it was used to just be like,
when you see elk smashing into each other in the wilderness,
that's what it used to be.
Being a man.
You would just run into a guy and just start punching each other.
And then with it,
those were the days back in the good old days before writing shit down
was,
people had a few mistakes,
just started writing shit down.
They were like,
oh yeah,
okay.
Yeah,
blame it on a Robbie Robbie's fault.
And that gentleman is,
his name is Sharon,
Sharon,
Sharon and Lucas.
And they're from a grindhouse wetware and grindhouse wetware.
First of all,
greatest name for a competent,
amazing ever.
What does that mean?
Uh,
so it comes from the name,
uh,
grinders.
That's what we get real close to that.
Uh,
that's what we are.
We're grinders.
Grinders are kind of like a,
what happens when you make open source hackers and body modification with a dash
of transhumanism.
Uh,
and what wears a is this,
you know,
your body.
So we're literally grinding our biology.
There's all these interesting little names that you guys have for yourself.
Close fall grinders.
We're grinders,
we're transhumanists where there's a lot of uh,
self defining going on there.
Well,
it's not exactly that we're self defining.
We're just guys who we really liked technology and we all grew up with like you
talk about growing up with Hemingway and classic men and we were all about
fighting.
We grew up,
we were,
we were protected and sheltered and grew up with star wars and grew up with
these stories about robots I could think.
And people that couldn't live any longer and had to augment themselves and
cyborgs and well,
cyborgs were really cool.
We thought they were really cool.
And uh,
you know,
I was in my twenties when we hit the year 2001st thing that happened,
New Year's Eve,
2000 and after I got over the shock of nothing hitting the wall,
nothing falling out of the sky,
I turned to my brother and went,
where is my fucking jet pack?
And that kind of summed it up.
I felt that way.
Um,
my buddy's felt that way.
I didn't realize it,
but there were a lot of people who felt that way.
And,
uh,
we were all broke and we didn't know much about science.
And,
um,
somewhere along the line,
like I guess in 2006,
there was a kid in Arizona who realized that he could start stimulating his
nerves with magnets,
with magnetic implants.
He,
uh,
went to a body mog guide and got an implant done in his fingers.
It started going from him to a guy in Europe.
And then like 2008,
there was a,
uh,
lady Quinn Norton,
um,
who wrote for wired and wrote for some other or other places.
And she did it.
She went out and said it was a bad idea.
Don't do it.
Um,
other people started doing it.
so
let's back up.
First of all,
explain what you're talking about.
You're talking about bio hacking,
talking about doing something to your body that enhances it in integrating,
incorporating technology into your body.
And the first guy was the guy in Phoenix that did the Arizona rather was at
Arizona.
Was it Phoenix,
Arizona?
Yeah.
They did the magnets and its fingers.
As far as we know,
that's the first,
the pioneer.
As far as first document,
what benefit is there of having magnets in your fingers?
Like what,
what did that accomplish for him besides making it easier to put your hand on a
refrigerator
easier?
I think it's annoying.
I'm being annoying moment.
You're always getting stuck to things.
Yeah.
It doesn't exactly work like that.
These are really tiny magnets.
Magnets in your fingers.
Yeah.
I got like,
uh,
got wound around there.
One around there.
Wow.
So,
so you implanted magnets in your fingers?
Yeah.
Why'd you do that?
Uh,
I was drunk.
No kidding,
kidding.
Um,
I uh,
found out about this.
I was really interested in everything we've been talking about.
I ran into a childhood friend of mine who got it done last year and when he
showed me what he was doing with it,
I had to do it.
What was he doing with it?
Um,
it gives you the ability when you implant a magnet in the nerve dance area of
your hand when you are around an electromagnetic field,
um,
that magnet vibrates.
And so you can feel that now there is a property of our brains called
neuroplasticity.
Uh,
when you provide a stimulus over a course of time,
uh,
like about six months,
your brain starts to it,
it starts building something new.
And,
uh,
I was always fascinated even as a child of a,
the idea of having an extra sense,
not necessarily like ESP,
but just an extra sense or be able to hear a sound that no one's ever heard
before.
Is he a color?
No one ever seen before.
All those stories from a don't do drug pamphlets that were like,
I can see the music,
I can taste sound.
That sounded amazing to me.
So when I heard about this extra sense,
I jumped at the chance to incorporate that in my body.
But what extra cents,
the extra sense of using these magnets to detect and electrical field or to
vibrate during an electrical field?
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah.
How would you define an electrical field?
Um,
it's our station.
It's an electromagnetic field.
So anytime that an electron travels in a straight line,
uh,
you have a magnetic field that's coming out kind of in a circle around it
radiates around it.
Um,
if you have a coil,
a coil of wire and the electrons going through a coil,
there'll be kind of like a doughnut shape,
magnetic field around it.
So those sorts of fields,
they have property of a volume and property of frequency.
They vibrate at a certain,
certain frequency and they're loud or soft like a transformer.
Like we'll watch,
we'll transplant.
We have a building that absolutely.
So if you were near that with your fingers having the magnets in them,
what would happen to you?
Um,
I can feel those sometimes.
Uh,
when people would ask me at the beginning what it was like to feel this stuff,
I would describe it like an effort of effervescent feeling like bubbles if felt
like bubbles.
And it was really interesting to me.
It felt like bubbles.
Yeah.
Like how does that work?
Well,
it's the weirdest explanation for some of that or description.
Oh,
felt like bubbles.
I don't even know what to say.
Yeah.
Kind of like fists,
like pop tarts,
pop rocks runner.
Seafoam I think his wedding,
I don't know.
Froth like dog froth.
Every person that has the implant uses completely different language.
It's been really fascinating to run into other people with implants and talk
about this stuff because we are describing the same phenomena and it's like
you're asking me to describe a color that you've never seen before.
How am I going to describe squad?
Uh,
it's squat.
Was that blue?
No,
it's squat is a purple.
Uh,
no,
it's like a tasting.
An orange.
Oh,
so it's orange?
No.
Is there any negative repercussions to having these magnets installed in your
body?
Um,
well,
the first time that someone actually said something that made sense as far as a
negative thing,
I saw a speech by Quinn Norton where she said,
Hey,
don't do this.
This is a bad idea.
Um,
hers shattered.
What?
Shattered her magnetic implant shattered.
Shattered.
Okay.
So when a a magnet receives either a lot of heat or a very strong force,
uh,
it loses its magnetic pole.
But more importantly,
these magnets are made out of rare earth elements.
Mine's like a cobalt a alloy.
Those things aren't really healthy to take inside your body if it shatters.
So this is paralleling,
coded.
Some people use silicone,
um,
crazier people use hot glue.
Um,
and yeah,
so it's essentially,
it's,
it's poison.
You're,
you're dealing with a toxic.
Yeah.
So body when it's not covered,
when a Burstyn in her,
she actually consulted a doctor and the doctor was like,
well,
here's the thing.
We could go through all the trouble of pulling it out,
but it's so tiny and it's so little that's really not going to bother you.
And so they left it in and over the course of time,
that magnet pulled itself back together.
She never got the sense back,
but it pulled itself back together.
Yeah.
What's in it didn't harm her.
Creepy little creature.
If you guys are interested moving around inside of her family,
she break it.
What'd she slap?
A cop car or something?
How would you,
how did she shadowed?
She didn't say serious masturbation.
I have no idea.
Just furious possessed eyes rolled back one shoe on screening.
Like a,
like a tiger cotton.
A Barb wire fence.
Hopefully it wasn't.
Yeah,
it could be cool.
I think that's what happened if I had to guess,
but that usually doesn't happen with,
with the magnets this size,
you don't have a vagina,
so I wouldn't know.
How could you know what would happen when a woman's in the middle of a furious
masturbation session
on thick fucking half a pound of meth?
Just slamming it home.
You never know.
Are you asking how can we imagine what happened?
I can get shattered.
That's just a good a guess as any.
Yeah,
like maybe her orgasm was so strong.
It admitted and magnetic field mashed up.
Horny as fuck.
Maybe on top of an old truck in the middle.
I'm just coming up with a scenario.
How do you did these are under,
these are under your fingers.
No,
that's a lot larger.
But if you guys are curious to cock magnet.
Yeah,
yeah.
There you go.
So I need something for your cock.
That's neat.
You know,
just in a cleaner way of expressing this question.
Um,
are there any gentleman perhaps that,
uh,
have these magnets putting their nether regions?
I have no idea.
I don't know.
I think so.
It's been spoken about.
It's been spoken.
Has it been smoking or has it been written on our website somewhere?
Uh,
it's been spoken about and you close,
you can get that to your face to see the better.
You should live right up to your face usually,
uh,
or move your chair a little bit when it comes to stuff like that.
People talk about it and then,
and then don't do,
oh,
so they're saying,
hey man,
but thinking about putting magnets in my car,
just so you started thinking about their cock,
is that what they're doing?
That's what they're doing is and the,
and then your forest,
hate me.
No,
Mike,
he's going to put magazines cock to be like,
why are we sitting around talking about Mike's car?
It's a lot of shit to talk about in the world.
But Mike tricked us and Mike brought up putting magnets in his cock.
He knows how to reach you guys.
Okay.
If he can't just talk about sex,
that's too easy.
No,
he has to talk about what,
what do you guys like?
You guys like putting magnets in your body?
So he starts talking about magnets his cock.
But people are in with like
absolutely,
totally serious.
This is,
I figured it out.
I'm,
I'm like Kojak or some shit.
But people already do that with body modification.
You know,
they do write stuff.
Pierce,
I've seen allegedly seen some stuff online and just horrible ideas.
You know that someone followed through with drunk splits,
his cock and the guy.
Only one guy that's like saying big foot's only one thing.
There's a lot of big foot.
You're saying more than one guy's flying on an answer tonight.
Why would he do supercar?
It's supposed to feel phenomenal,
I suppose.
Doesn't it fall apart when you're having to go hot dog that's been sliced and
thrown on the grill?
It's kind of like shooting like a shotgun.
Oh,
Daniel says that.
Wow.
It's Christ.
Yeah.
Don't,
I think you guys are,
you caught your Dick and then you just tell everybody it's awesome.
You don't want admit you're an idiot.
Is this like when they told me like we're going to have a punch yourself in the
face contest and I had to start for
exactly preposterous.
You guys are are in a way,
what you're doing is you are turning yourself into a lab rat with the intention
of gaining a kind of low level superpower,
like a really,
really low on the scale of super powers,
the ability to feel EMF fields.
Is that what they're called?
Yeah,
he did feel that that's a really low power,
but it's still,
you have more super powers than me.
I can't feel that you're still ahead of the majority of your species,
but there's a risk to this.
You're risking your life so that you can feel what it's like to be a
refrigerator magnet.
Anything that you put in your body,
you risk getting sepsis from.
There's a risk of sepsis.
So yeah,
there is a risk.
What exactly the Sepsis,
the sounds except Dick,
what does it mean?
It means some sort of infection and the way bacterial infections of any sort.
So I've had a buddy who's a surgeon who told me,
hey,
don't do this.
This is a bad idea.
Good for you.
You got that done.
But don't put anything else in your body because any implant can go septic can
go bad.
Yeah.
I got my nose pierced and Venice beach when I was 15.
And you should have seen that man,
you swell up.
Oh my God.
You know,
was just so nasty,
man.
My it,
my nose got swollen.
I pushed,
I remember pushing against it in front of the mirror.
Just like the
amount of pus,
like where you get proud of the amount of pus coming out,
you know,
that can kill people,
staff like that.
And then ones of eating your whole nose off.
Oh yeah man,
I got lucky.
You know,
you should never get your nose pierce.
That's a ridiculous thing.
But,
and there's no super power in that and you just look like a dumb ass what he
said.
Um,
with them.
so this is a changeable extra cents though,
this disability to detect a magnetic field.
I mean,
you really tend to do something that Dunkin or I can't with your body because of
these additions.
It's,
it's,
it's profound.
It's something I didn't understand when I got it done.
Um,
what started out like feeling bubbles?
now like,
uh,
I'll go to home depot and I'll be feeling stuff because it's,
oh my God.
So fun to feel stuff.
Fuel,
nice person.
He's feeling mainly magnetics
freak hanging around,
home depot touching all this stuff.
Oh my gosh.
It's like you're ill.
Oh No.
But just hands down by the lawn mowers.
The magnetic field.
Oh,
hey.
What's your favorite?
This means you probably have like people our favorite flavors.
Do you have a favorite machine you like to put your fingers in there?
Um,
I've had situations like I,
I've been around really strong magnets and when the first,
uh,
was around a really strong magnet,
I felt a feeling in the pit of my stomach,
like dread and,
and it made me want to pull away and run away from it as your word.
Clinked no,
it wasn't a logical thing.
It wasn't,
it wasn't a logic.
You know,
the funny thing about that is I'm working out what our sensitivities are.
There's been a lot of debate among the people who've had these things on how,
how close we can get to an MRI.
There are some people who talk about it being dangerous because it can,
you can move around.
Since this is subdermal,
it's not anchored in any way like a other subdermal a body mods are,
um,
it could move your magnet a bit,
one way or another,
someone's got to test it.
But,
uh,
there are people who've claimed,
through the network of people who install these.
There are people who have claimed that they've had a Mris done and felt their
magnet dance around and that's it.
Wow.
But the Mris,
a super powerful magnet that you're talking about,
that tiny
ones are like 1.5,
1.5 Teslas.
But people go into those things with sweater.
Is sweatshirts with the zippers on them?
They do.
Yeah.
I talked to a guy who operates when in research facility and you,
that's why I'm like,
funny you should mention this because,
but that's not standard operational procedures.
1.5 post it.
You supposed to get down to robe.
I just had one a couple of days ago.
He take your clothes off that you don't,
you don't go.
You sure they weren't just fucking with you?
Are you sure you don't know anything about MRI magnets and stolen your hand?
That's crazy man.
You don't go in there with zippers on what kind of a fucking doctor these people
going to,
it's a research facility.
It's not.
Joe,
can I get what you said?
Someone's died from an MRI.
What is that?
Well,
I was trying to say is if you have metal in the room when they turn the MRI on a
child died recently accidentally because they had an oxygen tank and the room
and they weren't aware they had it in there.
So when you turn on the MRI,
the fucking oxygen tank comes flying into the machine.
Ah,
giant,
super powerful magnet and it killed them by the time they could shut it off,
he was already dead.
I mean it's insane amount of pressure you're dealing with and it's just cause
someone's dumb enough to have metal in the room.
So I really find it hard to believe that any doctor would allow someone to go
through an Mri with a zipper on.
That's preposterous.
That's just not what they do.
So I question who you're talking to.
Him talking to crazy people lying about putting magnets in their dicks and
wearing zippers into Mri.
So you gotta hang it.
You've got to hang out with a higher quality.
Grew up with humans,
a higher quality room.
But,
but there is,
there is a magnetic shielding cause you know people that have pacemakers or
other implants.
Oh they put like something over you to stop that.
No suit or something like that.
Yeah.
Huh.
That's interesting.
But you're not doing that with your fingers.
You just let him tingle if you get in there allegedly don't know and somebody
really should be careful about.
But I think,
I think,
I think it's something that should be tested.
I think if we've even,
even if you're not,
I'm not advocating that someone with this in their finger go in and test it,
but you know,
even if you can replicate the consistency of human and put,
uh,
like a human flesh,
right,
demand it in and then expose it to something like 1.5 Tesla just to see what
happens.
Now you have this which you've already done with the magnets.
What is,
what's the next level thing?
Obviously everything progresses.
So what did,
what are people considering doing now?
So,
um,
we're doing well,
a lot of people are building devices that interact with a magnet.
So you can think of it as a,
because it interacts with electricity and magnetism.
It's kind of like a really low level input.
You can input anything.
Uh,
so if you've got an external device that's measuring,
say the amount of co two in the room,
you could hook that up through a coil around your finger,
around your,
your magnet finger and have that information transferred into like pulses or how
much it vibrates or whatever.
So you're literally using an external sensor to to give you data,
any data,
any data you want and have it transfer that to the magnet.
And after,
after some training it becomes intuitive.
So,
uh,
you know,
some people have done it with mainly sonar and thermal,
like a,
like a thermal laser.
Now I know that people have talked about the ultimate,
the all the,
the ultimate future of incorporating technology and the human body as the
ability to take the mind and download it's consciousness somewhere into a,
an artificial creation.
But somewhere along the line is probably going to be some steps.
Right?
And you guys are kind of taking like one of the steps,
like by putting magnets in your body.
When do you think you're going to see someone who puts a cell phone in their
body?
Is that coming?
Is it going to be like a neural interface that allows you to get online with
Wifi?
Well,
we're somewhere towards that.
That's something else we're working on.
So,
um,
our CTO,
his dream,
the thing that brought us all together wasn't magnets.
That was,
that was ancillary.
He was love,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
of course it was love because we all kind of knew each other and we all had this
love of the future and we all kind of were told to sit back and let Motorola
take care of it.
And none of us wanted to deal with that.
Um,
but he wanted to build something that he believed that we have the ability to do
this stuff ourselves.
We don't have to wait for some big company to do it.
We can do it cheap.
We can do it ourselves,
design ourselves.
And since we know people who can install magnets under our skin,
why not and implant?
Why not something?
Well,
the goal was to have something.
So basically what it does is a,
it,
it's a,
it's a rose compass,
uh,
that electrically stimulates you.
It's,
it's probably here on your cath and it's always pointing north so that you
always have an intuitive sense of where north is.
Now if you've got,
if you've got the chip talking to some external thing,
you could hook it up to a map system like Google maps and be like,
Yo,
take me home.
And then you have an intuitive sense of where home is always,
wow,
wait a minute.
What?
Hold on.
Wait back that up.
You have a compass and stalled in your body and the body,
how does it run?
It just runs on the magnetism that's in the compass.
It's all mechanical.
Is that electronics involved?
Right.
It can be powered wirelessly.
So it's,
it's got like a wireless coil in it and it's powered somehow by an external.
Yeah.
Okay.
And so you can like hover it over it.
That's,
that's what the dream is.
And what is the method of communication to the mind that explains where newer
north is or how to get home.
It's uh,
in the same way that you're using a really simple system in terms of the magnet,
you're not using any magic.
It's just vibrating for this.
It's just applying a very,
very small amount of electricity enough that you can,
there's,
there's a sensation so it's not like blaring and it's not shocking you,
but there is a sensation.
Is this completely theoretical,
the idea of being able to find your way home or is there any we,
we have,
uh,
parts of it,
parts of it built.
And actually when we came together and we had that idea,
we said,
okay,
this thing has way too many features.
So what we're gonna do is we're going to build a,
we're going to build an implant that's kind of a halfway step to there so that
we build the ground,
uh,
towards it.
And that's actually,
it's actually this thing here.
And so what this thing does is it actually,
it's a quantified self,
a health metric.
And this is,
uh,
this is just going to take data.
You can check this out.
This,
uh,
takes medical data and sends it to your phone.
Uh,
so if you can imagine having maybe six months worth of,
uh,
of your medical data and it's your data,
it's not anyone else's data,
your data,
um,
and you can do whatever with it.
Uh,
and so we wanted to kind of make,
do,
do a halfway project so that we get familiar with implant technology and then
move towards really cool shit.
The,
I,
I d I,
I understand.
Um,
the idea of a compass,
I understand that you,
you could power it somehow,
but what I don't understand is how the compass is communicating with your mind.
So in the,
in the same way that,
uh,
the nervous system is,
is communicating with your mind.
It's not,
uh,
it's not sending it wirelessly to your brain right there.
There are things in your body that's communicating to your nervous system that
then goes to your mind,
right?
And so you're literally,
uh,
you're literally making a new mini Oregon that,
or another part of your body that interfaces with your nervous system through
electricity.
And then
you're just saying it's like a vibration or something.
It's like a low level pulse or something.
Right?
It's a low level.
I understand that.
I understand that you would get a sensation,
but I don't understand how it could be directional.
I don't see the mechanism.
Well,
it's,
it's a,
it's a rose compass,
right?
So what does a rose compass mean?
It's a,
so it's got a clock.
Yeah.
It's got a north,
south,
east,
west,
and then northwest.
Oh,
that's called the rose compass.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh,
so it's a compass.
Yeah.
And yeah,
it's,
it's a compass.
And so,
uh,
let's say,
let's say I'm facing north,
the stimulation will be going this way,
right?
But if I,
if I turn,
it's gonna Start.
So start,
stimulate.
It's directional.
It's direct that wherever the north is,
it gives a signal or warning where the Arrow goes.
Yeah.
So narrow and not just,
doesn't just act as a beacon.
It's somehow or another like sends a charge off in that direction and then it
becomes intuitive.
Once you start determining what that signal means,
like it becomes a new thing,
sorta like sound like you hear sound over here and you know,
it's coming in that direction.
So it's crazy intuitive
in the sense that like I would be working with a,
with some of the guys in the lab and you know they've got two or three implants
and they would say leave the soldering iron on and they'd go to reach to grab
something and just them feeling this,
the,
the intensity of the soldering iron would make them pull back.
Right.
And so it's not like they're like,
oh shit that,
that might kill me.
Let me pull back.
It's more like,
it's more like every time you reach over here something screams at you or,
or something like pokes you,
it's like people who are allergic to cats,
if you're around the you,
that's a kind of superpower a person is allergic to.
Cats can walk into a house and be like,
you have cats,
right?
You have cats.
They can sense the cat cause they start sneezing and coughing.
You're dirty and you know,
clean your house.
Yeah.
Well generally people have cats,
cats,
gross,
a little creatures.
He felt it.
When you walk into a house and you get that first waft of the cat litter box and
mixing it with Old Bananas.
So Nice.
You have a box of shit in your house at night.
Nice dirty vox as shit and have had a filthy,
which animal want peering out at you from the wall ready to smother.
Your baby won't sleep and suck the breadth right out.
Are you guys going to destroy cats?
That's awesome.
Um,
I think this people like you make me love existing today because the idea that
there are human beings at this very moment,
and I picture you in a basement in,
in basements with straight razors,
shaking,
cutting themselves open and just putting chips inside of their doctors and have
all this done,
man.
Fantasy
leather straps download twig.
Now.
Well,
guys are both right.
You're both kind of rights.
They don't all go to a dog.
What doctor do you go to?
What doctor do you guys go to feel good or evil?
Dr Evil.
And,
and,
and I imagine that when before you guys put the magnets and you're snorting
oxycontin or like you're definitely on painkillers,
right?
I got it done with no pain meds and uh,
oh my gosh.
Um,
it was a rush.
I never had that much.
That's a new man do to stay down there with a razor blade in the photo says,
I got to tell him without painkillers and oh my gosh,
what a rush.
I don't.
It was,
was,
it was something else.
He mounted with endorphins.
He got,
it's,
it's trauma,
it's trauma.
Your body is going through trauma and your body releases all that endorphins all
at once.
You,
you,
you definitely,
you don't remember the fact that you just got hurt?
I don't,
I don't advocate people doing this to advocate in the opening themselves up at
all.
Uh,
that's not going to stop anybody.
It's too late right now.
There's already 700 teens with exacto knives putting their dad's wristwatch
Bandana in mouth and tongue.
But kids,
if you're watching this like seriously slate,
don't kill.
It never ends.
Well,
someone already it and they're kind
of fucked up because of it.
So tried what?
Um,
uh,
so one of the people that pioneered this,
this,
uh,
lady out in Scotland called lapse and an him,
she did this talk called cybernetics for the masses,
um,
where she advocating,
you know,
implants and uh,
she did it herself.
She,
she sterilized,
uh,
what did she,
she used,
she used vodka.
She uses vodka and hot glue to coat the magnets.
She uh,
in her speech she told everyone,
hey,
I don't care how hardcore you think you are.
Get a spotter.
Yeah.
And as you will pass out.
And that,
that to me,
she also used a vegetable peeler
to me.
That to me is not,
is not DIY cybernetics.
That's irresponsible.
It's Bailey.
I'm going to tell you that when you told me her name,
you don't leave at home with your keys.
I've seen that speeds weapon and I emailed her directly after this speech
because I wanted to get her on my podcast,
but she,
first of all,
I didn't know she was a she cause she's Androgynous,
you can't really tell,
but she looks like she fell out of a Philip k Dick novel.
Like she is a really fascinating being.
Like it's a really curious being and she seems kind of nonchalant about what
she's doing and it reminds me of you guys a little bit because you guys seem to
be brushing off the fact that what you're doing can make it so that in 20 years
you are just basically a trembling drink machines.
Somebody could put a cocktail in your hand and makes it up because you have some
kind of severe neurological damage from the weird chemicals in your magnets
going into your brain.
It could be true.
You're right.
Totally right.
We probably would be dealing with something worse than a Parkinson's like state.
We cannot get up on the mic.
I'm sorry.
That's okay.
Um,
you're right.
There are risks.
Um,
when left gave that speech,
he gave it with the intent that people out there would see her process and go,
oh my God,
you could do it so much better.
You could do it so much safer.
And when people are talking about what grindings about and why it's called
grinding,
that's part of part of the spirit of being a grinder is being open about your
processes because you're hoping that someone will look at your processes and go,
Oh yeah,
I see what you did.
I see how you made it better.
I can make it even better and even more so.
Why Grindr?
Um,
so it,
it originates from a comic book called Doctor Sleepless and uh,
there's a great guys a door.
No,
they're not door.
It's awesome.
I want to be a bad thing,
but you guys are dorks and so there's,
there's not a dork.
So bad thing.
These are pioneer dork too.
How dare you.
You're a Dork.
I guess I am a Dork because that right now you read walking dead comic books.
You're a dork now,
man.
That's into tell me I have to read a tense.
Do you got to read him?
He's a Dork.
That does nothing wrong.
It man.
The son Ronald,
being a Dork.
Don't be scared of being a Dork.
Oh,
okay.
Well fine.
I'm a dork too.
I'd rather be a Dork with magnets under my fingers are not going to be a Dork.
I like to be a Dork with a low,
bad to be a door.
But the fact that you guys call yourself grinders out of a comic book,
that's clearly pretty Dorky,
but it's not bad.
[inaudible] you embrace being a Dork.
I'm,
I think the term Dork is a dorky term.
No,
it's an awesome term.
And that's what we were when we're out there looking for bigfoot.
We were two dorks here,
by the way,
having a time of our lives with fuck doors.
There's nothing wrong with being a door.
There's no disrespect intended,
no disrespect.
It's,
it's,
you know,
you're not taking yourself that seriously.
You never in your whole group after college.
Yeah.
Uh,
part of,
uh,
part of what we do is,
um,
is using,
we're still using the scientific method.
We're not just like,
sure.
Well,
what we're doing is we're putting our method out there for it to be criticized
so that it's safe in,
in our community.
Right.
And we're,
it's not,
uh,
you know,
cut yourself open with vegetable peelers and it's not,
it's not have,
it's not,
have the method be held up by the FDA for 50 years.
It's about knowing what the risks are as an individual and deciding whether to
take it or not.
That's that piece of it.
Plastics,
silicon,
whatever it is.
What it,
what does that exactly mean?
I don't think you showed me earlier the chip.
Oh,
that's,
that's regular circuit board.
There's all sorts of bad shit and therefore women wasn't made out of fiberglass,
copper or metal plastics.
Where would you put that?
Inside a a silicone silicone shape.
There was a bio proofing process,
like a sheath,
um,
like a condom,
silicone condom sort of thing.
More like a,
uh,
something more secure.
You take a CNC,
you make a CNC mold,
uh,
reverse.
So this isn't an unpopulated board because all of our regular prototypes are
being tested.
Um,
who on on four function functionability functionality,
functionality,
it,
Keating,
it crushing it.
So once we're confident that we have like something that can handle the stresses
that we think,
uh,
someone who would have something in it for a year,
which is our goal.
Like get it inside someone for a year and take it out.
Then we're testing bio proofing.
Bio proofing is doing a pressure injected silicone mold.
Oh Wow.
That's just sounds like it would hurt.
Do you guys have in your car that's not inside you?
You
want to know though is like what part of the body would you install this thing?
Well,
Tim's been talking about the forearm.
Why the forum?
Because it would be cool to look down at your arm and see LED's lighten up
underneath your skin.
Yeah.
So that's part of it.
You guys aren't just pioneers trying
to read a fine humanity.
You just want to have shining lights under your scan.
Some dork pussy.
Let's be honest.
We are Jeff,
many different types of
dead man.
If you're,
you're a super baller in the grinder community.
If you walk around with a glowing implant on your arm.
Yeah.
Do you guys have a,
in your community,
somebody who you know,
will put anything under their skin,
like somebody who walks around Jangling with metal pieces and lights.
Is there,
is there a person who's got the most implants?
Uh,
no I don't.
I don't think we've reached there yet.
What's the most incredible,
like the most extreme implant that you're aware of?
Maybe rich.
Yeah.
Probably fucking rich.
Rich is going on with rich.
So,
uh,
he's got,
two magnet implants in his finger and he actually has,
um,
he has a coil,
like a huge coil that he uses to,
uh,
to be able to like hear radio stations and all sorts of craziness.
They're basically implanted earphones.
Wait a minute.
When he has,
he has magnets on his fingers.
Ears in his ears.
Ears.
Yes.
Magnets.
Yeah.
So he's got his fingers in his ears.
Xochi said.
Yeah,
he's got,
um,
he's got like two minutes.
Ears,
ears.
Man.
That's scary.
Yeah.
They'll use easy to operate on your ears.
He's intense.
And so what's the coil?
The coil is a,
like a,
any coil.
It's stimulating these magnets makes of magnet vibrate.
So he hooked up this coil to a,
a little amplifier and that amplifier sending sound through it,
like a,
your standard speaker,
right?
Right.
You send sound through a speaker coil,
it make some magnet jump back or makes a magnet a forced the coil back and forth
and you make sound.
So he's using this,
uh,
sending electromagnetic waves to,
the magnets in his ears,
his magnet stance around,
and they give them sound.
So he was able to,
uh,
use a Bluetooth connection to his phone to hear his phone through as invisible,
your phones.
That's insane.
Yeah.
So,
yeah,
it,
it sounds really crazy and dangerous,
but I think,
I think there's,
we're also trying to establish a precedent that we want.
Like we,
no matter what organization pops up,
there's going to be cyborgs in the future.
And I,
I think,
I think that that's what we're listing.
That's what we're moving towards.
And I think that we want to move to a future where people are openly
experimenting with themselves instead of having to go to one source.
Uh,
you know,
like company x to get their implants.
And I think there's,
there's a sort of liberation that you have by either making your own implant or
knowing,
knowing what
it was made of,
who coded it,
what the code is and,
and all sorts of stuff.
So in our community,
we share all of the information there is,
there is no weird outside control because everyone knows how it was built and if
you don't like how it was built,
you can change it.
Cyborg,
if you wear glasses,
is the Nordi incorporation of technology into the human body.
I try to avoid like the word Cyborg because the moment that people start saying
Cyborg,
everyone's like,
you're not a Cyborg.
Cyborg.
Start this.
And that means,
yeah,
some someone made with a machine,
these things you have sitting on your face and that's how,
that's how you see better.
And without those you wouldn't see so,
right.
Good.
I think I thought a Cyborg,
it means that it's part of you now.
You can't take it off like it's permanently in you.
Yeah.
You've learned hearing implants.
Those are first steps.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Hearing aids,
but you know what else is crazy and dangerous learning to build an airplane.
Like think of the Wright brothers way back when,
when they were telling people we're going to try to make a device that makes us
fly like birds,
frightened,
terrified.
People like are you out of your mind?
You're going to fall,
you're just going to fall to your death.
And it's true.
There is an implicit risk whenever you're trying to create some new invention.
And if you wait for the FDA,
if we sit around and wait for apple or for Microsoft to get this stuff passed,
it is going to be 50 years,
a hundred years because we need you guys to turn it.
A few of you are going to have to turn into the toxic avenger.
A few of you are.
It's true,
man.
You need it.
Cause they've made themselves Guinea pigs for the sake of our species.
They did it cause they're enjoying it.
Yeah.
Well it's worse than a 50 or wait and what's,
what's bad about it?
Microphone.
What's bad about it?
Thank you.
No problem.
Uh,
what's bad about it is the fact that there are people who can afford what an
implant would cost.
And um,
like with cell phones,
I saw cell phones be a tool of people who had tons of money.
And I saw that with every other technology.
And when you're talking about modifying your body in the ways that we are
talking about it,
and it seems like it has so much potential to be a useful tool for people to
make that something that's only available to people with large amounts of
capital seems like wrong.
Well then you go on,
listen,
don't curse
dirty address this.
And quite accurately when he talks about technology being applied in the cell
phone world,
he's like it initially it was just a privileged few.
He goes now like 70 plus percent of the population on the planet has cell
phones.
He can go to the jungles of Africa.
You find people have cell phones,
people have cell phones everywhere you look,
which,
so it starts off like it's really expensive.
But if it proves to be effective,
it becomes accessible to almost everyone.
Which is true.
But,
uh,
but if you look at,
if you look at waves of technology,
right,
and the evolution of technology,
the people that get it first get to dictate how the technology is used and they
get to dictate the political landscape,
right?
So my,
my awesome.
So for example,
you'd look at the on users
don't get to dictate the political landscape.
So who has,
that's the one.
Yeah,
but it's not cell phone producers.
You're talking about people who buy him.
You're talking about people who can afford to use them.
Now they're saying that they're saying that when you,
a cell phone is invented,
when Verizon builds a cell phone,
they get into an agreement with the NSA and there's code inside your cell phone
that makes it so that it's tracking you.
It imagine,
imagine,
imagine that technology applied to,
to some kind of implant.
Imagine if they came up with some neuroprosthetic where,
uh,
you know,
the neuroprosthetic that you can attach to your hippocampus that allows you to
record your memories.
Imagine if the government invents that and it has some secret code in it.
They can shut off your brain.
Okay.
But that's not new.
What they were talking about,
they were talking about privilege to people.
You're talking about this priority.
He prior to owning ownership.
So like,
uh,
with cell phones you have chips that,
that are really good at decoding video.
Really,
really good at it.
And they're really tiny and you know,
they're also kind of cheap,
but they're not open for everyone to you.
So when you have something like the raspberry Pi come along,
they have to beg,
what's a pie?
It's a handheld computer.
35 bucks.
Does everything regular.
Yeah.
It's crazy like that.
They like on Reddit it always pops up with something you've never heard of
raspberry.
It's just a super cheap operating
system.
Right?
It's a super cheap computer.
Oh,
it's a super cheap computer.
It,
it's about the size of a credit card.
It does everything that computers should do.
So you can get on the net,
you can use a to do credit card.
Um,
it's credit card,
palm sized.
It's palm sized.
It's a screen as well.
No,
you need a screen keyboard.
Uh,
whatever interfaces with the boss.
It's the CPU,
the whole deal.
The box itself stuff.
Wow.
That's credit card size.
And they had to make deals with a nondisclosure agreements and make all sorts of
deals to attain the technology for their cell phone parts that they're using in
there that's not open to everyone.
So you know,
in that same way we believe that people will create better when they get the
keys to the candy store and they can actually experiment with all the parts that
are being used and being developed as much as possible.
We want to encourage that plane and playing.
That's interesting.
But uh,
what do I,
what I was concerned with more was not the,
uh,
the people,
um,
that are going to profit or not profit from creating these things.
I was talking about people getting access to the technology itself and it seems
like that's inevitable.
It seems like if it's effective for rich people,
it will eventually trickle down to the rest of the population no matter what as
long as it's really worthwhile.
But I,
I think that when you've got a particular group of people always getting first
access and they can always
determine how it's used.
And by the time the technology is democratized to a point where it,
you know,
first advantage,
it doesn't matter,
then there's something else because they're sitting on the capital from the last
thing that came along.
So you've got this perpetual cycle of,
well,
we're making it first.
So we always get to dictate the terms of which this,
this thing,
the legal and technical terms by which shakes this thing or this type of thing.
Yeah.
But isn't that what ingenuity is all about and isn't that why people spend so
much money on companies to try to develop products?
I isn't that like sort of their mo the motivation,
the motivation is to capture the market place and to be able to sell this
incredible thing that they've created.
I think you're saying it should be locked down.
No,
no,
no.
I'm saying it shouldn't be long.
Yeah,
but I'm saying I meant locked down as in once something has created a,
basically it's available to everyone.
It shouldn't be available just to this one person that created it.
Yeah,
I think so.
And I,
I think,
I think that's,
that's the most ethical way to do it in,
in this case because,
uh,
when you're talking about augmenting humans,
you're talking about giving them additional information about the world.
And this is our most powerful tool ever.
And so when you,
when you're talking about supercharging this,
you're giving individuals and it's a great advantage over others.
And with any other technology,
you know,
there's abuse.
If you look at nuclear technology,
right?
Uh,
the Soviet Union and,
and the United States got to dictate foreign policy for how many years because
they had that and other countries didn't.
And I,
I personally think that that's the scale of power we're talking about when
you're saying like neural implants and,
and all of these really powerful devices.
I think that the first people that get it get to dictate how everyone else
plays.
So you're essentially,
what you're saying is that these new technologies are going to be so powerful
that once people get control of them,
they'll literally be able to enslave great groups of people who don't have them.
They'll have power over them,
they'll have advantage over the over them and they'll decide or could decide to
use that advantage to control the monopolize,
the use of these technologies,
monopolize the use of these human improvements.
He's technological human improvements and they'll just hoard them.
All of themselves.
Yeah,
I mean,
and not in any,
does anybody ever done that with anything technology?
Has anybody heard the technology ever for themselves?
It seems like if you can sell it,
people sell it.
Well it,
it never,
it never lasts long,
but what I'm talking about are the ram,
the social ramifications of,
of people trying to hold on to that for whatever.
Cause for example,
everyone,
every army today uses guns,
but we're still reeling from the cultural effects of one group of people having
guns and another group of people not having guns.
Right.
We're still reeling from,
from,
you know,
countries hating each other and an ethnic tension and whatever.
So it's not,
it's not so much about technology,
it's about,
this is what happens when you,
when you try to lock it down eventually it's going to spread.
But you're causing damage by trying to lock it down.
Right.
That seems to be a,
I dunno,
it's a,
it's a funny argument.
It's an interesting argument and it gets into a social engineering or socialism,
uh,
point of view where you got to go.
Well,
how do you decide to distribute a technology?
There are companies like ate a fruit,
I ate of fruit spark fund,
they're open source and they still make money.
Well,
there certainly is.
I mean that's a,
if any place embraces open source,
it's the Internet and technology and you know,
of course Linux and Unix and there's always been a whole open source community
online.
But to dictate that,
that's mandatory.
That's where things get sketchy.
You know what I'm saying?
I want,
I'm not saying that I don't want a future where corporations don't sell this.
I want people to have options.
I don't totally understand what you're saying,
but it,
it goes against every other way.
We manage innovation and we,
the way we manage innovation,
it's people get copyrights,
trademarks and you create something and that becomes you and then you own that
and then you could sell it or license it out to other people.
Well,
you're essentially saying is that whenever it comes to a human benefit now,
no longer do you have the option.
Now you're going to distribute it freely to everybody.
And I,
I say like you're,
you're,
you're regulating like in a way that has never been regulated before.
And that's the socialist idea.
And it's intriguing.
It's interesting.
Um,
it's debatable.
Interesting.
And it's debatable,
but what you're,
what you're talking about is a sort of a mandatory type of a thing.
Well,
I,
I don't wanna I don't want to say,
hey Google,
you have to make this,
this implant open source.
What I'm saying is I want a future where you can either get corporation x or you
can go to the open source community.
Be Cheap.
Right?
But isn't that inevitable?
I mean,
that's what you have with cell phones.
you can buy an android phone or you can buy an apple phone or you can buy some
no name phone.
I mean,
eventually if something is worth something,
people sell it to the point where you're going to have leaders in the
marketplace.
But once it has,
once the public has access,
those leaders are based in the market itself.
There based on what people buy,
what they like,
what they enjoy.
He can't monopolize if someone,
if,
if everyone's selling a similar product and one person's better,
that's the one that succeeds.
And that's,
that's sort of where we're at because of the fact that we don't just say when
something comes along like,
hey,
everybody has access to this fuck patents,
fuck trademarks.
You know,
that that's literally against the way innovation has spawned human beings to
this point in the first.
But there's other,
there's,
I think there's other motivations than capital.
I think they way the motivation in this kind of technology is so much bigger
than money.
What you're talking about is achieving,
uh,
the ability with technology to produce emotions or to create psychic states.
Uh,
that is,
uh,
an amazing thing and that's an amazingly powerful thing.
So so's calling people.
Yeah,
but you know what,
I'd rather have an orgasm helmet than a cell phone,
but it's,
look,
it's not either or.
It's not either or.
But what I'm saying is cell phones didn't get socialized and this technology
shouldn't either.
I don't think they're saying it should or shouldn't be socialized.
I'm just,
they're,
they're trying to make an open source version of this stuff.
But if they do that for us,
I don't think they're going to do that before.
It knows what they're doing.
But what I'm saying is
you make it,
you shouldn't be entitled to distribute it to everybody if you want to
you,
but you shouldn't be.
You shouldn't be forced into Detroit.
I wonder if future of options and an end and in terms of the technology coming
out,
I want the open source and the closed source to come out at the same time
because any,
any lag time between the closed source and the open source,
again,
it starts to produce,
produce problems.
So I want a future where people have options as to what they're going to get.
And I think that we've already seen problems with,
uh,
with technologies being pigeonholed so that,
you know,
we can't have,
we can't not have a smartphone,
but we know the fuckery that's going on with smartphones.
Right?
And so there's what,
what do you,
what do you do?
Well,
there's a lot of problems with smartphones if really want to get to the bottom
of it.
The real problem is they're all based on conflict minerals.
The real problem in smartphones is that you follow every smart phone down to its
source.
And he got a little kid in Africa with a stick knocking rocks out of the dirt.
And that's real.
And that they can't fix that yet.
They really can't.
They don't know what to do yet.
So the,
they need these conflict minerals and they're not available in very,
very many spots of the world.
And the places where they can get them the cheapest,
that's where they get them.
And that's why you have civil war in the Congo.
And that's why you have people fighting over these resources.
So you've got a real problem besides the innovation got a real problem in the
morality of actually owning a cell phone because everyone who owns a cell
phone's a piece of shit.
If you really get down to the core of it.
I mean this just,
there's no way around it.
I,
I think this is a,
this is an unbelievably fascinating subject and I think it's inevitable that,
uh,
we,
we have this sort of discussion and the,
in this argument and I think what we really need is the idea of capitalism or
competition.
W merged with morality and ethics and humanity and in,
instead,
what we usually have is he who gets to the top of the mountain,
kicks everybody in the face that's trying to get up and instead of like pulling
people up with them and humanity benefiting and,
and,
and sharing something like that in an open source manner because you think it's
the right thing to do instead of mandating it,
I think it almost should be a part of success itself.
That success itself sort of generates a altruism.
It generates happiness at generates generosity.
It should.
It's like once you have some and you care about others you should give,
you should help,
you should boost him up and we don't have that attitude,
this country.
Unfortunately we have this ultra competitive attitude which has spawned so much
innovation because of it,
but along way it's also made a bunch of fucking assholes.
Yeah.
You know a bunch of heartless assholes just caught up in the hunt.
Don't,
don't you guys think that the,
it's eventually going to be impossible to keep anything private and that it's
like to even the,
so we're entering into a future where there is really not going to be such a
thing as secrets.
We're entering into a future where everything will eventually be leaked in some
way.
Everything will
well,
I'll go you one better.
I don't think money's going to be real anymore.
I think we're going to get to a point where there's not going to ones and Zeros
are not going to cut it as far as you have this and he doesn't have that and I
really believe that we're going to get to some weird place where just by nature
of the,
the just the progression of technology itself,
the dissolving of boundaries,
the access to information ones and Zeros are all you have when it comes to
money.
Money is just information.
It's going to get to a point where the idea of the paradigm that we operate
under,
we think it's important.
I keep my stuff,
you keep your stuff,
I pay for this,
you pay for that.
It doesn't exist anywhere else in nature.
We've decided that this is normal.
We're going to get to a point in time where you're not going to be able to lock
it down anymore.
You're not going to be able to hold on to money.
It's not gonna mean anything.
We're going to have to decide what the fuck to do with all the different shaped
houses.
We're going to have to decide who gets the food.
It's not going to be real anymore.
It's going to,
it's going to merge and do some next level shit.
And that's the future of humanity.
I hope so too.
But then I hope people don't get lazy as fuck because of that.
Well one of the reasons why people have done so well,
which is it's also arguable whether or not doing so well as a good thing.
But one of the reasons is that we've needed to succeed in order to survive.
I don't know.
Can you think we got out of caves?
How do you think we didn't get killed off like neanderthal?
How do you think we didn't become food for the prey were weak and slow.
We'd just,
because we,
we innovated and we pushed forth and we got the fuck away from all the things
that are dangerous.
We locked up cities,
we invented guns,
we did a lot of shit in order to make innovation possible.
Cause if you go to places on the earth,
like the Amazon or like Africa,
there's no fucking innovation.
Okay.
You're wearing a piece of skin over your deck and you look for something to eat.
And that's what you do everyday.
You get up in the morning early and you go look for something he cause if you
don't,
you die.
My,
my,
my favorite,
my favorite example is the,
when we started growing crops right before most of our,
most of a human's time was spent looking for food.
Right?
You didn't have time to ask,
you know,
mom,
what is that?
Cause you were fucking either hunting something or running away from something
that was just about your entire life.
When you are now growing food,
you're now,
you now have a wide space in your day where you're not doing anything,
even entire seasons where you've got food stored up.
So what do you do?
You started asking questions.
You started making art.
You start writing things down because you've got time.
Now.
I think that when I think technology should be about liberating people to do
what they want fall,
I'm sorry to cut you,
but what you're saying,
this to me is one of the great,
uh,
naive ideas of transhumanism,
which is the notion that if you remove from human beings and this then the need
for something.
In other words,
because the ultimate goal of transhumanism,
I think is to take the,
to shrink down the moment between what you can think you want and the moment of
having it to nothing so that you instantaneously have something,
whether it's by neurologically stimulating your brain in a way that's exactly
identical to reality.
So you can experience any feeling state that you want or whether it's using
matters simulators to build something that you've contemplated and all of
humanity has been based on overcoming the obstacle between those two things.
But in overcoming the obstacle,
you gain wisdom when you're learning how to like play piano,
you don't just get to learn how to play piano.
You get to learn the discipline of years and years of working to play piano and
suddenly we can download into someone's mind how to play piano.
If we remove that discipline,
then what Joe's saying is you end up with slugs.
I think that,
I think no matter how hard a dog tries,
it can never learn calculus.
There's just an upper limit.
You just,
no matter it can study forever and it just,
it won't happen.
And so I think that there are things that we just,
as humans,
we just,
no matter how hard we try,
there's an upper limit.
And so when you begin,
let's say downloading information,
there's some things you'll get easy,
but there are other things that no one's ever discovered that you now have to
discover new ways to play that have never been even,
you know,
thought about ever.
So I think that that when you,
when you augment,
when you make yourself more intelligent,
more capable now,
now you don't have to do hard work to do what humans can do,
but you still have to do hard work to do whatever.
Explain it in layman's terms.
This is a technological version of Mo money.
Mo problems.
Exactly.
That's what it is.
Yes.
You don't get make your problems far more complex like people thought.
You know what?
Once human beings have supermarkets and you just go with a credit card,
you don't even have to bring her on a bag of gold,
then no one's going to be depressed.
It turns out people more depressed.
They're sad,
they're looking for meaning.
They're not hunting and gathering their food.
They're missing all those,
those,
those rewards that are built into the human genome,
they don't get them anymore.
So what do they do?
They take Prozac and they drive fast and they watch stupid movies.
Yeah.
Well can I put it a little money mo problems.
Well,
let me put it in non layman's burning man terms.
If you'd take the Tibetan book of the dead,
one of the Bardos or one of the hell's in the Tibetan book of the dead is called
the Hell of hungry ghosts.
And what this hell is,
is these beings living in this weird place have this infinite appetite and
anything they can think of to eat immediately appears in front of them.
So they have the combination of always being hungry,
mixed in,
being able to instantaneously
create any food that they want and that creates a health state where all they're
doing is feeding and eating to try to quench this endless human appetite.
Now obviously we're really far away.
Probably coming though.
I mean if you wanted to think of something that someone would invent,
that's without doubt inside the realm of possibility.
We already have boner pills for old dudes on a pill.
The on their deathbed,
they chomped down a couple of pills and they got us Zombie talked.
We already have that.
You're telling me they're not going to have something where it just keeps your
hunger going.
You,
you never get satisfied.
You'll be hungry all the time.
What's your favorite thing to do?
Isn't it eat mine too?
Wouldn't it be great if you were hungry always and you can just be a
professional eater all day.
Yeah.
Fast food.
Thinking about what people had done to their lips.
People would do that.
People blown up their lips putting magnets in their fingers.
No offense.
They would definitely do that.
I,
I think that that,
that's a,
if that's something a negative about the human condition.
I mean if,
if we have that technology at some point,
then we would also have the technology to change it.
And that's another discussion whether we should get rid of the hedonic
treadmill.
Well,
I'm not even sure that it's a negative.
I'm just a,
it's almost like a pattern.
I mean,
I think whatever it took to get humans to this point in history,
whatever it took to get us to what we are now,
it's an incredible process.
I mean from whatever we were from multi-celled organisms on to this thing with
laptops,
that process is insane.
And the idea that that process just changes because we add a chip and you know,
we,
it's a no,
I was going to be,
there's going to be like a growing phase and then it's going to become something
new just like it became this.
Yeah.
If this is unrecognizable to some crazy Nana tall 50,000 years ago and it's what
we will be 50,000 years from now,
it's probably unrecognizable to us.
Yeah,
and whether it happens slowly or quickly.
What has happened in our lifetime,
man did the idea of of the Internet,
it crept up on us so damn quick that we all just accepted as a fact.
Whereas if you brought any other time in history,
it's the most insane piece of sorcery and magic the world has ever known.
Just 20 years ago it would have been insane conquering,
conquering a dragon.
The idea that you could have a little little glass box and your posture and
answers all your questions,
amazing.
You could send messages,
including video from people to people all around the world.
It's insane.
Everything about it since the credible and it's just a part of our accepted
everyday life slowly happen slowly or quickly,
whether it'd be,
you know,
slowly.
We think of it slowly in the course of human history.
It's a massive burst of innovation.
But in our lifetimes it's been 10 20 years and then boom,
it's all here.
But the idea that you're going to stop it,
that,
you know,
or that we should even resist the next level is it seems pretty silly.
I just can't resist it.
You can't stop it.
It's interesting to sit around and go,
what the hell is it going to be?
Yeah.
That's where it gets weird.
And,
and we don't know,
but no,
I don't,
I don't think that,
uh,
primitive man could have put a person on the moon if they were still worrying
about catching that pig.
You know what I'm saying?
Whatever,
whatever aspirations we will have in 10,000 years,
we won't get to that if,
if we don't do certain things.
Uh,
and,
and I think that a part of,
uh,
a part of humanity that I think we should keep is our need to explore and
understand.
And I think that if we're still worrying about,
you know,
getting cancer at 60,
we're not going to get it
there.
Right.
I think it's inevitable,
but we still keep exploring.
I really don't.
I don't,
that's why we're here.
It's a whole part of the whole thing.
There's no getting around that.
Now you've got a video to show us.
Oh,
well we've got a something Kikwete queued up with Tim when,
when our buddy,
our CTO got his magnets installed,
uh,
he,
he got it on video.
Okay.
Yeah.
Loans.
Definitely see that.
Slapped that up.
Oh,
Jesus.
Yeah.
This is Tim.
Oh my God.
What's what?
You don't know.
What's that sound?
Hold on.
Pause that.
Why does it sound like that?
What kind of soundtrack is on that?
That's so stupid.
Kill the sound.
Just play that because obviously there's something going on behind it.
We might even be a movie.
Wow.
Okay.
Doing the surgery.
Some asshole if I'm at home depot.
They were to around touching lawn mowers.
It's like,
Hey,
I can do that for you.
He's someone who,
uh,
does,
does tattoo work and he specializes in doing subdermal stuff.
Wow.
Shitty tattoos.
Never trusted tattoo artists was shitty.
Taxes cause a thing called old laser tattoo removal sun looking into it.
Never trust a surgeon was shitty.
Tattoos,
especially on his face.
Tazzy surgeons with tattoos on their face.
Boy Floyd,
you're going to go under and 10,
nine I to fuck you man.
Your ass.
Wait.
Okay.
So this guy is cutting and he's inserting this magnet into this dude's
fingertip.
This,
it's a very,
very,
very tiny magnet.
Yeah.
Well how,
how would you describe it?
It looks like a BB that's been split into like sixes,
right?
That's all small looks.
It's about two millimeters wide.
It's a little gel that's bigger than I thought.
Maybe,
maybe a little less than two millimeters
cause that looks really tiny.
Maybe it's just a perspective,
uh,
of this,
this video,
but that looks like,
well under a millimeter.
What's the charge for this procedure?
Three guys crazy.
Absolutely.
100% free talks you up,
stick shit in your fingertips and that's who you get
stuffed down from.
Uh,
it'd be pretty reasonable.
It'd be a bargain price anywhere between 75 and one 50.
Just like most subdermal uh,
body mods.
What is,
um,
when you're talking about the future,
when you guys sit around and you,
you bring up what's on the horizon,
what's like the big theoretical on the horizon as to have anything to do with
like the kind of technology that we see in Google glass being incorporated in
like maybe a normal sort of a thing.
So there was a,
there was a paper put out a few months ago about,
uh,
connecting two minds of rodents.
Uh,
and so there was one road and if I'm not mistaken in Virginia and there was
another road and somewhere in Brazil and they put this chip into the,
into the brains of these two mice and put them through an obstacle course.
And,
uh,
with a US roughly 60 to 70%,
um,
uh,
crossover rate,
the other mouse actually learned,
uh,
the obstacle course of the other mouse.
It was connected to.
Do you know if that's been done without chips though?
Rupert Sheldrake wrote a whole book about it.
It's called the morphic field and a morphic residence.
And,
uh,
he wrote a book,
about a dog's knowing when their owners are coming home and uh,
people being able to tell when people look at the back of their heads.
And it's a fascinating sort of a theory,
but he,
um,
he showed that,
I don't know if it's been verified 100%,
so,
but I know he wrote that he showed that if you teach a rat in one place,
a maze that rat somewhere else,
another part of the world will learn that similar maize or that same May.
It's quicker,
statistically quicker.
Right.
They've also shown that chimpanzees,
once they started venting,
um,
things to do with tools,
chimpanzees,
we,
they've demonstrated like,
um,
a,
an orangutan in Africa learned how to spear fish by watching people do it.
There's a picture of this thing doing it.
It's all a motherfucker.
It's the craziest thing ever.
Well,
other rang,
started doing it too.
They once,
once they start learning things,
it's almost like it's in the ether.
It's very strange.
Yeah.
This is a ring of Tang separated geographically.
It's not like they could observe each other.
And I don't know about orangutans,
but the,
um,
the bice definitely separated geographically.
That's what's odd about it.
But you know what,
I think,
man,
I don't think it's that they're learning,
they learn it and then it travels somehow through space.
I think the evolution sort of groves through us,
do you know what I mean?
Like it's our,
it's,
it's something that's growing through humanity is,
are these new innovation.
So it's not as though one orangutan figured it out and send out a signal.
It's as though this was just a new phase that was coming through this form of
that's very possible.
Well,
but the Orangutang initially I,
I've confused these two stories pretty badly,
but the,
uh,
the mice learned in separate parts of the world,
separate parts of,
they weren't connected,
whether it's a thousand miles or a hundred miles,
whatever it was,
but the rank Tang,
we're watching people and the orangutan started imitating people,
so they did directly imitating human beings.
But if you really stop and think about when human beings used to be essentially
very similar to orangutans,
it was probably only like a couple of million years ago.
Right?
That seems like a long time to us,
but in the span of the universe,
that ain't shit.
So the idea that a chimp could eventually,
if they kept moving along and slowly innovating and changing and finding magic
mushrooms and learning how to make fires with rocks,
they could eventually become some kind of a human thing.
I mean,
we didn't use to be people.
That's a fact.
I mean pretty much established.
It's not like all of a sudden we popped up in this form,
you know,
figuring out always shit.
We've got to get away from leopards that we,
we,
we became this like slowly and steadily.
It's just the timeframe for us.
It's so bizarre to wrap our heads around with an 80 plus year lifespan to try to
understand what a 10 million year period of development is.
We can't really,
we can't get our head into that.
We don't,
we don't know what that means.
And 10 million years from now with this stuff.
When he gets to that weird exponential technology thing that's going on right
now,
we're going to be unrecognizable a hundred years from now.
Sure.
Well that's what I feel like Lucas is getting at.
By creating an actual in a pathway between two minds or between many minds that
we can control using principles we already understand.
I don't know.
Intuition the way I know the way in electrons going to travel.
I know the way in electrons going to travel.
I don't,
I don't get intuition that way.
So if we can create chips where I can have something in the back of my head and
I go like this and Lucas is like stop scratching your arm cause I feel it.
Yeah,
like that's,
that's like that's an SRO
touching your butt.
How about that?
Like sitting around your house all of a sudden,
no Lucas stop.
No,
you're on a date.
You're trying to keep it together.
You could get hacked with that kind of technology somebody could hack into seems
inevitable.
Just like you get those.
Like someone hacked Twitter today and I must've got a thought.
I'm not bullshitting a thousand fake tweets about diet and exercise.
Oh Wow.
I look so good for summer because I started doing this.
Like those,
those bots,
a Bot got through and just infected.
I think the benefit of having a bunch of people develop their own technologies
together.
Well No.
If you're developing your own technologies for your own implants,
there is some sort of,
there's some sort of level of of security like some people use macs because hey
macs don't get viruses the way pcs do because people who want to write viruses
are targeting pcs cause there's more pcs around.
I think that is a blinking oasis in the desert.
We're going to be able to stop anything from getting hacked.
I think the idea that,
well first of all we've learned about the NSA and spying.
It's already shown that there's that you can't,
you can't stop it.
They've already got algorithms in place already copy and all your emails because
of,
because of bottle bottle,
net technology because it,
because can't invent
our own internet.
There is,
we can only use that internet and that Internet goes through certain filters
you'd use also because these fucking corporations have given in to their
overlords and giving up the information.
I mean that's it.
And that's really where it comes down to.
I don't want to live,
I don't want to live in a future where I've got artificial organs and all of the
information from that is being pumped out to some who the fuck knows.
I don't,
I don't feel comfortable with that.
I want,
I want that information to belong to me at least,
so that I can do what it with what I want.
You know,
I don't want any advertisements because my liver is doing whatever or I don't
want people to be able to shut off my liver,
my liver,
cause I'm not being a good citizen.
Imagine the Second Ethan Hawke Movie.
There'd be no Snowden.
Yeah.
When his brain would have melted out of his nose by now,
they just turned him up,
man.
I'm sorry.
You guys had to take a leak.
Go ahead.
Go to the coconut water.
Crushes me every time.
Um,
where,
where do you think the end game is when it comes to all this bio hacking stuff?
What's,
what's,
what's the end game like?
Where do you hope that it all winds up?
Do you have like a man and I hope by the time I'm x years old I can fly.
I mean,
is there a,
is there something like that
I can go first.
I see an end game as,
as something way larger than people screwing with their body.
It's,
it's,
it's a whole bunch of different technologies that are happening all at once.
And the fact that we don't have no resources on this planet to support the
population growth and the amount of people that we do have and those sorts of
things add together.
I feel like when you look at a company like space x and what space x is doing
and,
and the fact that all these technologies are leading towards longer lives,
uh,
the guy who's doing soylent,
the,
uh,
food substitute guy of those dudes,
dudes in New York,
really awesome science stuff.
Yeah.
Isn't it a drank it,
I was like,
what am I drinking?
And I think all that adds together and I think that,
you know,
when we have so many people and we're living a longer time and we have the
ability to print anything we can conceive,
then maybe it's time for us to start moving out to space.
Maybe it's time that we can handle 20 years over to somewhere where we'll be
doing heavy construction work in zero g so that other people can come there and
live and be smarter and move forward from there.
Maybe it's time to start space colonization and
space colonization.
That's where we're gone.
It'd be going to be,
Cyborg is here for us.
He could be like,
download your consciousness into a robot and send the robot in the space.
I honestly think plastic brain,
it's the smartest way to do it is to be a side where if you're going into space,
so what I've been saving everything in space is,
is trying to kill a biological organism.
They can't,
you know,
uh,
apes in a tin can,
won't cut it.
I said what I'm saying.
Uh,
and I think being able to withstand all of the crazy space,
weather,
space,
condition.
Yeah.
The conditions are insane.
I mean,
the,
the temperature is instantly death if you step outside,
unless you have a pressure suit,
if you get hit by any sort of a solar flare or asteroid,
you're done.
Were,
were,
were too fragile even for this planet.
That's why we've got this stuff on us.
And I think motorcycle jackets and shit.
Yeah.
The idea of,
of,
uh,
colonizing space as this,
I don't think it's,
it's,
it's too dangerous.
Do you foresee a future where we really do download our consciousness into some
sort of an artificial human being?
I,
I don't know.
Uh,
I don't know enough about the technology to say anything definite.
I think that it's a cool idea,
but I've never seen anything compelling,
compelling,
so I can't,
I can't really say
it's a mind fuck.
Oh.
And then the idea of like a little,
you a little Lucas running around,
made out of rubber and it's you,
your consciousness is in this thing.
It's out there touching things and moving stuff around.
Yeah.
And also that you could duplicate a Lucas.
Like if you could download a Lucas,
then you're Lucas getting up on the on pirate bay.
People could just be downloading you and then sending you pictures of their
Lucas that they've put in some kind of habitrail.
But that would definitely be another.
That would be another loop
guess so because once you start generating independent memories,
I think you start having different emotions,
different thoughts about things.
Yeah.
That's going to be really weird.
Unless they all interface somehow or another together,
which is,
yeah.
Which,
which I mean it is possible,
right?
I mean if you're dealing with,
look,
the idea of sending someone a video or talking to someone through facetime or
Skype in real time off your phone seems like the dumbest,
the craziest thing ever.
Like that couldn't be possible.
That wasn't even on Star Trek.
They never even figured that out on Star Trek.
But it's real.
The idea that you and your three clones or whatever they are could be
experiencing life simultaneously and that you could multitask and that the mind
may evolve to concentrate on one person or the other.
These two sleep or these two are out,
you know,
and you're doing two different things at the same time and aware,
tuning into either one,
whatever you choose.
It's sorta like touching your leg with your left hand while you're writing
something with your right hand.
It's going to be a problem man.
You're going to have swarms of individuals.
There's going to be Rogan swarms like kingus Khan,
like Gingiss cons,
responsible for like something like 5% of the population's DNA cause they just,
you know,
he went on a party and spraying the 12 hundreds and the whole world has never
recovered.
You know?
Imagine if you're doing that artificially stuff that's that powerful.
All of a sudden it becomes really important.
Who has control of that technology and the initial five.
But how do you enforce that?
It's a race.
Hold on a second.
What?
What about them?
About it's cough cause that's where he wants to create is this whole army.
Did you guys,
you want to create an army?
Well,
not an army army,
but a whole group of people.
He does live forever.
Um,
did you,
uh,
pay attention to the global future 20,
45 conference?
Yeah,
I know about the 2045 guys.
What do you guys think about that?
Um,
I like that,
uh,
that they're working towards a solid project,
because that's kind of rare in the transhumanist community.
There's just a lot of Scifi talk way too much,
just too much.
That's fine.
Discontent and the transhumanist community debating on how to handle this
correctly of know what the fuck he's doing,
what his robots.
But uh,
I liked,
I liked the fact that they have a goal that they're working towards.
I just,
I fear that,
uh,
there'll be a particular group of people that'll,
that'll get it and then just fuck us for eternity.
That's your big fear,
your big fear of someone else getting ahold of the goods first and not giving
you the super chip.
I,
I fear about the type of people that'll,
that'll get it first because the world didn't fair well when a particular people
set of people got the gun first.
That wasn't good for a lot of the human species.
Well,
it was good for us though.
That's how you're here,
dude.
That's how you sitting on the Internet and I know with a plastic microphone in
front of you sucked out of the earth.
I would verted from oil.
I would rather,
I would rather not have to move forward with that sort of contention and
fighting and just pee.
I don't,
I don't think is that inevitable with enlightenment.
I mean we have w w w whether or not we've achieved enlightenment,
we certainly haven't,
but at the highest levels of humanity,
I think people are probably more aware and tuned in today than at any other time
in history and it's probably way safer today than any other time in history.
Even though there's a lot of crazy shit that goes down on a regular basis.
If you compared your everyday life to that.
If someone living in Siberia in the 12 hundreds in the Mongols came storming in
it,
we live a lot better.
It's a pretty pretty God damn good.
I,
and I think that a big part of that is technology and the access to information,
the access to information is freer than ever before.
Technology more powerful than ever before.
Hence people are safer and people were more moral.
I really do believe that and I think the idea of people being moral is more
accepted as not just something that has to be enforced in order to keep the
peace,
but that's something that's beneficial and something that you would should
strive for.
It's admirable.
I think that that really meant it might not have existed on such a mass scale in
the past,
even in the past 20 or 30 years.
I think we're dealing with like pretty unprecedented times and it sounds like
really super,
you know,
optimistic.
But I feel like one of the byproducts of this technology that we're all
experiencing is that we're experiencing a sort of mini enlightenment and a a
burst of enlightenment because of this information.
If that is the case,
I think that this kind of technology,
that it sort of dissolves more boundary.
I don't think it's going to lead to a constriction of the people that utilize
it.
I think it's going to lead to a freedom of the species itself.
I really do believe that.
I think that if I look at the,
the trend,
even though everybody wants to think the sky is falling,
the trend is an indicate that,
that the sky is falling for some people in some spots and the apocalypse is
right now,
if you live in,
in the Congo,
if you're in Liberia,
the apocalypse is today.
That's Mad Max,
right?
That's going on right now.
So,
but the trend for us here,
it's obviously not in that direction.
I mean it seems like there's always going to be a worst case scenario on this
planet,
but that worst case scenario is far better today than it's ever been in history.
And the best case scenario was completely nonexistent.
Even in science fiction novels,
it's going in that way.
You can't stop it.
Yeah.
Wait until one of these,
one of these people in Venice,
swarm of Nano,
it goes flying out of their basement devouring toddlers.
I mean,
the thing is like I liked the toddlers Sandler.
It's a fun word to say.
It's your thing.
You always go with dead baby,
but,
but no,
I think that when you're talking about this kind of stuff,
you're,
you're talking about acceleration.
I think you're talking about a technological acceleration and wherever there's
acceleration,
there's an increased chance of hurting yourself.
If you're on a skateboard going a few miles per hour,
you're fine.
If you're on a skateboard going downhill,
you can wipe out.
Well,
humanity is on this technological skateboard that's exponentially accelerating
and in that way,
the role of the individual becomes more and more and more intense,
which means that with this kind of stuff,
when the individual has access to the kind of technology that they have today,
they can do a ton of damage.
Look what happened with those freaks.
All they needed was a pressure cooker and some ball bearings and they
permanently,
yeah,
they killed so many people and traumatize so many others in the same way.
Five years from now.
What happens with when people have access to this kind of stuff,
it is day.
It is.
We are setting ourselves up,
but for your time
about very unique in individual circumstances in comparison to the 7 billion
people experiencing things completely differently all around the world.
The problem is that you're dealing with 7 billion people that have access to the
internet or at least a,
a good percentage of them and have their stories being told.
So you're hearing about instances all over the world simultaneously.
All at once.
We're not designed for that were designed to take in information from our local
community,
were designed to take information from all these abandoned dudes are about a
mile away on foot and they're coming here to fuck our women.
That's normal.
That's what we're supposed to deal with.
You're not supposed to deal with a story about a guy in Switzerland and fucked
his pig to death.
You know,
you know you're not supposed to deal with this guy in Detroit.
This got a,
a fake bigfoot in his cooler,
the outback.
These are,
these are all,
you
know,
this is,
this is just,
you're dealing with so many human beings and impossible number of 7 billion and
you're getting information from vast number of those people.
So you're always going to get these freaks you're always going to get.
But it's still the trend.
The overall trend batter is way better than it's ever.
And I agree with you there.
I,
my hope would be that we become more ethical before we get the power to cause
damage.
So we,
even though we're more ethical now,
any ethical mishap at this point would be a lot more disastrous.
It's not so bad when the most powerful weapon you have is a sword.
Uh,
yeah.
Well that's not true cause [inaudible] 70 million people doing worse than a
sword and a lot of people,
a lot of other dudes with them,
but they did it with horses,
right?
70 million.
Any ball over his lifetime with horses.
But the scenario is you have three d printers and let's imagine three d printers
in 200 years,
where now you can like molecularly assemble stuff and somewhere along this 200
years someone discovered anti-matter.
Right.
So let's imagine that there's a way someone could create a anti-matter that when
it met,
matter would dissolve the universe.
Let's just say there's an imaginary technology.
They could open up a note side of what's going to happen.
A few people are going to die and then it's going to force everyone to learn how
to be really nice to everyone because everyone can create a fucking anti-matter
bomb in their computer.
That's what I,
that's right.
Yeah.
That's what I,
that's what I hope.
That's what I mean.
They sale well on population is a polite population.
Well,
I mean the way to take it to the complete next level,
black holes all throughout our planet that were created by assholes.
We're going to have to hop over on our way to seven 11 there's a black hole over
there.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Something
humanism that people don't talk enough about,
I think is making people more ethical.
I think there's only talk of making people more capable and intelligent.
That's an implicitly,
there is no talk of making people nicer for the sake of just living in a,
in a more sane world because we're nice now.
But what happens if infrastructure goes away and they become hungry again and
we've got lots of weapons around what happens?
And it would,
it would take a longer period to build back up in this state rather than if we
were nicer and had forethought instead of having hunger automatically take over
and be like,
well,
fuck that guy.
He has food.
You know,
we,
I think that we should start having a discussion about,
uh,
making people more ethical,
and,
and be able to empathize with even other species because who knows,
uh,
who knows what we will run into in the future and that might be important.
That's interesting that you brought that up because that was something that
Dimitri Itzkoff actually touched on in the conversation that I had with him,
where he was talking about that being an important part of this whole movement
and that the movement wasn't just about achieving some new technological state.
It's about Everlane elevating humanity as a whole overall.
And I thought that was really interesting that he is taking that into
consideration.
That's one of the reasons why in this global future,
25 2045 um,
that's what it was,
right?
Global Future,
2045 conference that he had,
he brought in a lot of religious and spiritual leaders to sort of ask some
questions of these different face to try to get an understanding of what their
philosophies were and how they would incorporate this sort of new impending
technology.
Is transhumanism idea,
had it w were it to come to fruition.
It was really pretty fascinating stuff.
I mean,
he didn't just take it from the technological standpoint,
it's cough really delve.
He dove into the psychological and the spiritual aspects of it as well,
which I thought was a unique and admirable and probably pretty important.
If this thing moves further,
you're going to have some brick,
real ethical questions.
We develop immortal cyber beings with skin made out of spider webs.
Silk.
That's bulletproof.
I mean there's already,
that's common.
The track team anymore.
They're already there.
He figured out how to do that.
Yeah,
the transhumanist,
the Mormon,
but that's,
that's a real thing.
It's like saying gays for Jesus.
Yeah.
Is,
that's hilarious.
There is humanist Mormonism subset of the Mormon community.
The problem is if you're willing to be in a Mormon,
you're fucking willing to be anything.
It's just a matter of who rings your doorbell first.
You know?
It's like just to sit them down and talk them into anything.
You're a Mormon.
We believe a 14 year old,
they've,
Joseph Smith in 1820 found golden tablets that contained the loss work of Jesus
and only he could read him cause he had a magic rock.
No wonder whether afraid of gay marriage,
your family,
because if someone could talk into being a Mormon,
they can talk in a blowing them too.
That's the job that's right out of my standup.
God dammit.
He got me doing my own material.
God,
you are the,
you're a part of a movement right now,
whether you call it grinders,
a transhumanism or whatever,
you're a part of a movement where you're focusing on a very specific thing.
You're focusing on incorporating technology into the body to improve the body
and as long as you're focusing on that and as long as there's a whole community
focusing on that,
whether or not now it's just magnets and the fingers is everybody's poo poo in
it and saying,
what's the big deal is going to come a time where it's a lot more than that.
Whether it's some new invention of something that has absolutely no a rejection
in the human body,
so you can add all kinds of things,
whether that some new technology comes along that radically enhances perception,
whether it's visual or hearing or thinking cognitive function.
The ability to read each other's minds.
As long as you both have the chip,
it's all going to happen,
right?
Like you can't text message someone who doesn't have a phone.
Okay?
But if they have a phone,
you can text him pretty easy.
And once we all have something like that in our head and it's like your phone
will work with your friends' phones.
Oh Em Gee,
I'm looking at you right now and I'm writing this down.
You know,
there's going to be those moments where we,
we hit some next level that we didn't see common.
Just like we didn't see the internet comment.
We didn't see cell phones come in.
No one saw that shit coming again.
Even star track.
They had a fucking walkie-talkie.
Man.
Perk out.
Yeah,
like say that to shut it.
It'll flip it open.
It's so stupid.
They didn't see iPads.
I didn't see any of that shit.
And you guys are right on the crest of the wave.
Right on the crest of the technological tsunami.
Getting sucked into the singularity is,
we're all getting torn towards that waterfall.
You guys are in the canoes at the very front,
how far would you be willing to take it if someone came up with some real Steve
Austin?
$6 million man arms and legs.
They just had a saw your shit off and put on some new ones.
Would you be down if you knew if were like a whole bunch.
It was like fake tits where everybody was doing it.
If it got to that point,
I guess everyone was doing it,
we'd all do it.
Yeah.
It came up to like a woman in the 18 hundreds oh it came up to a pilgrim or
something and said,
listen,
I like,
I like when you look like,
but I'm thinking,
Hey,
some bags of water,
a surgically implanted under your breasts.
You know you get a lot more attention around the tax bags.
They didn't even have this bag,
didn't have plastic,
but they would think you're fucking crazy.
Are we going to think,
I mean is that US looking at the future about like it's going to be standard.
Like you still have your arms and legs.
Oh my God,
girl.
What are you doing?
What is that?
Yeah,
that'd be the end of rape.
Everybody's just fucking super robot retro thing though to have them fight off
everybody.
Yeah.
I think that Richard Gums in the cubs and expression of yourself kind of the way
that body modification is already.
No.
Why would I replace perfectly good arms and legs when I could have extra or
maybe something that ingredient,
see greedy motherfucker trying to give me a super body like,
oh,
but I have those three dicks but by the way,
then you got it.
Arms for us would be great if Shava maybe that's what she was all about me.
That is the feature.
A futuristic holy shit.
I never even thought of that.
Maybe that's what that was all about.
Some crazy transhumanists from the past.
Maybe they figured it out a long time ago and they're just barely wrote it down.
They were so high,
the road down like they were still a few passages in the Bhagavad Gita and then
went back to eat mushrooms.
Hold on 600 is that what it says?
But I do like that you ask somebody who has magnets under his hands.
If he had replaced his arms with the robot arms,
the answer was yes,
of course you would do it.
And even even if no one else was doing,
if you couldn't enjoy like foot massages anymore,
would you replace your legs?
If they were just numb,
they were numb but awesome like jumping over buildings,
running 60 miles an hour,
but they were numb.
You know,
you don't feel good massage.
Are you saying that
you feel nothing?
I don't think it has to be a uh,
a trade off.
I might have to be,
but if you keep your cock and balls but the bottom of your sack is numb.
The only way you can feel your balls if someone squeezes them,
but the legs on down fake as fuck.
Super powerful Pistons and
then you know,
nuclear power
jump over tree.
You're saying I could jump over trees but my falls are not all in the bottom.
The bottom of your balls or no?
Yeah,
I'll take all the way to that.
You think you would be willing to go through an operation of it removes your
legs.
I mean,
what if they get operations like look,
a long time ago you just something like a fake tit would,
you'd probably die if someone tried to do that to you.
You would die just from the fact they didn't know how to sterilize you.
You didn't have any way of putting you under.
Sure it was.
It would be nothing today,
but back then it was a serious,
serious thing.
Today girls go back to work in a couple of days.
The idea on the why,
I keep going back to fake tits.
I'm trying to find a nonsexist way of approaching this and far as male
enhancement,
but I can't find anything that's a standard as the craziness of Male,
a female breast enhancement.
It's one of the weirdest things.
Human beings still,
but tried to,
if we get to some point where amputating legs,
it's like nothing and we're replacing with an artificial one superpower.
Think that the difference between a breast implant and fake leg,
right?
Is that already my knees are given out already.
My,
my legs are going to wear out.
Stop right there.
I had three tests.
Three kids rather it you to chicks tits who's had three kids.
Everything wears out,
man.
We're made out of flesh.
Right.
Would've been way better if I said it's mother missed opportunity.
We stumbled.
We do wear out.
You're totally right.
There's nothing different between those two.
But we were out.
Yeah.
When we did eventually your choice,
it might be shitty legs or better legs
or maybe the fix the fix the um,
under sac and you know,
come up with some new technology that even though the under sac is artificial,
it has sensors and it sends it,
I would just like everybody here to stop pretending that if they had super
powerful robot legs,
you wouldn't get your legs amputated and replace.
If I see what,
I wouldn't be worried about the fact that they're numb.
That's a weird thing,
man.
I would want someone to do it for jumping over.
Treat people already working on that.
You know,
the field your face.
Yeah.
That feel people already an end.
We're working towards a more sensitive prosthetics that you can feel more.
Right.
And you can pretty soon.
I'm hoping that you can even dial it so that if you're going to do something
dangerous or painful,
you can dial the pain down,
whatever.
It becomes optional at that point.
It why would you keep these?
These aren't modular.
You can't switch them.
They don't rotate.
Yeah.
Why?
Why would you?
Because they feel good when you hold someone's hands,
but you can,
you can always put over a layer of,
of soft stuff.
Why
not just pretend you're alive and jump off a bridge?
I mean it's at what point in time do we end this?
Okay.
You get your whole body is going to be this fake robot body and you're needing
to take what is the memories of your life and your consciousness and download
them into some computer chip and then the sh the you rots and this dream you
goes wandering around to get batteries run out.
Yes.
Thinking you're really living on a farm with the Waltons.
Meanwhile,
you're a stupid thing with a battery.
You don't even know what the fuck's going on with your life.
Meanwhile you're some,
you're like holding hands on the beach and getting foot massages while all of us
are bounding through the universe jumping over buildings,
but I'm just playing devil's advocate,
but there always are those people that want to hold everything back and go what?
Like there was those assholes that we were listening to.
Science has yet to explain how a seed becomes a beautiful flower and the spa.
Yes,
actually it has dummy.
You know,
we were listening to these,
some of these religious people talking at that conference were just there.
The ideas were so stupid and antiquated can lean on to the the mysteries that
have already been solved,
but in what we were talking about before,
those mysteries that have been solved,
when we do understand the mechanism behind the seed becoming a flower,
make it even more fascinating because even though we understand the process now,
it's still,
wow,
that's cool.
Before it used to be a while.
That flower is beautiful.
What a mystery.
I'm so glad God brought this to my life.
Now we're like,
isn't this incredible?
This seed got oxygen and then minerals from the soil and then it converts it
into energy and then it's photosynthesis and it grows and then the flowers
blooms.
This is insane.
It's like the whole process behind it is like,
it's like so mind boggling and enriching and as a human being,
that's one of the things that like really jazzes us up when we learn new shit,
when we discover new shit,
it's part of like the,
like when you tell someone something,
go,
Whoa,
that's cool.
Like we were talking earlier today about this,
um,
this discovery,
these,
uh,
scientists,
in,
uh,
Germany and in Germany and America,
they have discovered this new type of animal that used to be like a,
an ancestor of the human being that's from 41,000 years ago.
They thought it might be a neanderthal.
They thought it might be a homosapien.
And it turned out to be some new thing that they didn't even know existed.
It's called,
they're calling it at Dennis.
So van,
based on where they found it,
and when we were talking about it before,
we were all like,
whoa,
cool,
la.
Like there's a,
there's a part of learning something new and discovering something new that just
jazzes us
and that,
that's one of the things that brought me to transhumanism,
the,
the desire to see the Milky Way.
I mean,
learning that we didn't live,
we couldn't live long enough to explore the galaxy was just to me as a kid was
just really,
yeah,
it was,
it was like,
you know,
you're a super geek.
I grew up watching like star wars and,
and you're watching doctor who,
and then finding out that were too fragile.
And we don't live long enough to see anything.
It's like we can't,
what we do is we say,
what's over that hill?
What's over that mountain?
Let's go.
I know it's dangerous,
but hey,
there's nothing else to do.
Let's do it.
And the fact that we,
we can't cross space because we're just too much radiation or theirs,
you'll develop wrong or whatever.
That to me,
that was devastating and unacceptable.
And I think that,
that,
that's just
what other option is there but to move forward.
That's so funny,
that devastating.
Unacceptable.
Do you,
you heard about the,
um,
there's a gentleman at the University of Connecticut that's the foremost
scientists,
uh,
it working on time travel.
Roy Mallet,
I believe is Ray Mallet.
I forget,
I forget his name,
but he's a professor and he started his work on time trouble because his father
died when he was a young man and he wanted to go back in time to save his
father.
So this guy,
he's like a goddamn character in a comic book.
He's like turn to a Spiderman book and he's been working on time travel to go
back in time and save his father
cool.
Dead.
But it's those,
those things like where you were like,
I can't imagine that I'm living in a world where I won't get the fly in a
Battlestar Galactica ship and fight the cylons.
This is ridiculous.
I think that's what's beautiful about transhumanism is that it has the impulse
within it is the same impulse.
They got people to go onto ships,
to sail towards a continent that they'd kind of heard about it.
The re risking everything with no food,
probably going to die.
Maybe the earth just ends.
I think there's something beautiful about what you guys are doing,
even though I do see it as a kind of self destructive act.
I think when you put magnets on your fingers,
you,
you aren't thinking ahead,
you aren't thinking about what you're going to be like in 30 years.
You know,
you don't know.
You could be the dude who used to have a nose ring for like three days and I
didn't get a nose ring back did and almost killed you.
You self destructive,
best damn bull's they to give me the nose ring was not the same impulse that
drove explorers through the sea.
It was just being dumb and high in Venice beach.
There's no glory to it.
What these guys are doing is glorious.
It's really cool.
It's just a kind of low.
It's a bit,
you have to start somewhere.
You know,
you gotta,
you gotta start somewhere.
You're starting with magnets in your fingers.
By the way,
if anybody's listening to this,
the,
uh,
the scientist was Ronald Mallet,
Ronald l mallet,
m a l l e t.
T from the Ph.
He's a phd at the University of Connecticut.
Would you like to meet Dimitri Itzkoff,
the man who founded the global future 20,
45 conference.
And if so,
what would you,
uh,
ask him
you first please?
What would I ask him?
I,
I would ask him,
uh,
did you say to him,
maybe it doesn't even have to be a question and do it.
Would you,
would you have anything specific that you would want to talk to him about?
I would actually ask him what his,
uh,
what his vision of the future is.
If it,
if it all pans out perfectly in his view,
what would it look like?
Cause I'm very interested in what his is.
I'd love to,
I'd actually love to meet him.
What about you?
Would you ask him?
I'd like to meet him.
I'd like to know what he thinks about where we're going as,
as a whole,
as a group of people who are experimenting with ourselves and,
and doing this stuff.
And I would ask him for it,
the resources that we don't have.
When you talk about how,
um,
putting a magnet inside yourself,
you can't think about the long term.
Well,
it's not that we haven't,
it's that the people we talked to who were professionals in these fields,
they can't risk telling us the answers because they have professional
certification boards that would say,
hey,
you're behaving unethically.
You're telling someone to do something harmful to themselves and they don't know
the risks that we're taking.
We're yanking your license.
And so we don't get answers to questions that we need.
And I think a guy like it's golf could probably put us in touch with a lot of
people would have a lot of answers for things I could really help us out.
Awesome.
Dude,
thank you very much.
Really fun conversation.
A really interesting stuff.
Fantastic subject.
And uh,
thanks for doing what you're doing.
Thanks for sharing your information as well.
You guys have a great attitude about all this technology too.
And even though I played devil's advocate about it,
I really think that ultimately that would be the best way and I'll fall.
We all had access,
but the problem is,
you know,
people are weak bitches
grindhouse wetware lazy.
Fantastic.
Good night.